all right denny
hi
danny where'd you grow up where are you
from originally from long beach but i
moved around a lot growing up
i always ended up back in long beach so
tell me about your family growing up you
had mom and dad yeah
my mom divorced
my biological dad when i was five
and she got divorced one more time after
with my step-dad
but that that was pretty traumatic
when
like when you're a kid you kind of
assume that
your parents like love you regardless no
matter what and that they're not going
to leave
soon after that my dad ended up moving
to peru
and
i haven't been in contact with him since
that was like years ago
and that definitely it left like
this need for like validation and just
it also affected my relationships with
men growing up as well
in what ways
um
i think i just felt this this like loss
and
uh growing up like in high school i was
always trying to like
i felt this need to like
have a boyfriend and be loved and stuff
and i think i was just trying to feel
that that like hole in my life i guess
how would you describe your childhood in
general like
teen years
unstable yeah yeah
i always felt like
there was something going around in my
life that i couldn't control everything
just was just happening around me
and that led to
mental disorders
yeah
when
when i was eight i was diagnosed with
anxiety for the first time
and i was immediately put on medication
i didn't really get a choice i was eight
but
i stopped going after a year because my
therapist moved and my mom just never
put me back into therapy
um but i was stuck like knowing that i
had this thing wrong with me i didn't
really it was i was kind of told not to
like tell anybody about it
um so
years of
of on like not treating that went by i
also
was like
kind of bullied a lot mainly in
elementary school and it just felt like
everyone in my life
like i wasn't accepted anywhere
um
one time
i i was in third grade this is like when
i was in therapy when i got diagnosed
and my anxiety started getting like
really really
i
had stopped like
talking to the kids in my class like
completely like i was like silent
and um
usually like i
i was a pretty good student i like
really really cared
about being a good kid i think it was
like a form of just trying to have like
adults
accept me because if i was like good
that maybe you know they would stay in
my life
um
so i had a
parent like teacher conference thing but
it wasn't just like my mom and my
teacher it was
my teacher a couple like other teachers
i think the principal
and
my therapist was there
and in that in that meeting
in front of everybody
my teacher at the time she she told me
that i was unteachable
and
you know like i was just that little
girl who
really really
wanted some sort of acceptance
she said that because
i had started
not doing math and i would flip over the
paper and i would draw
and that was kind of bizarre behavior
for me because it was so important for
me to be like a great student
and now now looking back
i i was coping
that
had become like my biggest coping skill
and i didn't even know like i was eight
i
there was like a lot i was dealing with
at the time
um so moving into like
middle school
is when
i feel like body image stuff really
started affecting me
even like as a young girl
um
all these messages that i got like from
media adults
friends stuff like that had stuck with
me like
all the adults that
like
all the female adults in my life from an
early age i remember them hating their
body
so that my i had this aunt she um
she dieted like heavily always
exercising always talking about weight
loss
and
growing up i had learned that
skinny and pretty equal happiness
or
like if i was pretty and skinny maybe
i i could have somebody like me
that that was like a huge thing was
my self-worth
had become very based off of what other
people thought of me
um
and in middle school this is when it
started getting really bad
i remember like getting ready for school
and stuff and
i i would um
i would start like crying i would get so
anxious because i hated the way i look
so much i would start like hitting
myself
and just like freaking out every like
every morning
getting
ready um
i
i think
this is around this time i started the
depression came in
i started getting like a lot more
depressed i remember
thinking a lot about
wanting to die i wasn't suicidal like
yet
but it had been become like a super
comfortable thought
with me um
and i always like judged myself because
i i didn't think that i really had like
trauma
um
you know like everyone
goes through like their parents 50 of
all marriages end in divorce i didn't
really think like
i like judged myself for feeling that
bad
and for feeling like i wanted to die
my life wasn't
that bad i
had a home
you know food clothes stuff like that
uh in eighth grade
my
my cousin he passed away
he was ten
so this this year like this last june or
whatever on he would have graduated
um that's that's when
like the depression got really really
bad
and i remember thinking like
why why did i why did he have to die
like
i i hated myself so much
that i
i
like i would have been like just take me
instead
you know he
he didn't deserve that
um
how did he die
my parents never really told me they
just told me that he got sick and he
passed away i think it was like cardiac
arrest but
um
i never really asked after i just
kind of
thought they didn't want to talk about
it
and that was like the first time i'd
experienced grief
it was really shocking because
he was so like so young
so on top of like
everyone in my life like kids at school
nobody liked me
my i was dealing with
the fact that my dad like the one
other person who was like supposed to be
guaranteed to stay in my life it was so
easy for him to just leave
moving around a lot i was unstable
just in the world my anxiety was really
high so i was just afraid
of everything
and then i started
directing all of this like onto my body
um
i guess
with eating disorders that's
it's really heavily based around control
and
my life i couldn't control anything in
my life so
i i can control my body i can control
what i put in my body what i do is it
how i want it to look
in ninth grade
i joined the water polo team at my
school
and i was only doing it because all my
friends were doing it
but
i started exercising pretty heavily
and even like outside of our already
really long and hard practices
then
i decided one day that i was
gonna go on a diet
and
i
i remember thinking like
that this was gonna
be something really good for me that i
was gonna
come back next school year be like
skinny and pretty and stuff
i also think it was like
guys didn't really like like me
um
and that was like
something that made me feel like even
more uglier i never felt pretty
until you know
i just i struggled with that a lot
so i started this diet
and it quickly
became
obsessive it quickly
it just became very
dangerous very fast
i
i started like counting calories um
checking my body a lot weighing myself
over exercising
to the point where i i wouldn't even sit
down
like
all day i had to be moving i'm pacing
back and forth
and it just got worse and worse from
there the behaviors got worse and worse
all i was
all i was thinking about was food and my
body and calories
and i wasn't myself anymore
i
i like
it turned me into another person but it
feels like
i am
became very like mean
because
if anything you know if my mom or anyone
express any concern about like okay you
don't need to be exercising right now i
would just snap on them
and
so that it just got worse and worse that
summer
towards the end of the summer
my aunt she took me on a trip with my
cousin
to new york and i was so so excited to
go
it had been like my dream to visit new
york city
but the trip wasn't what i expected
because by this time i
had a full blown eating disorder
so i didn't
try any of the foods i didn't enjoy
anything while i was there
i
i was like restricting the whole time i
was still trying to exercise even though
i was on vacation
and the trip was only like two weeks
when i got back
my mom saw me like
the amount of weight i dropped was
drastic for just even those like two
weeks at the end of the summer the next
morning she took me to um
[Music]
she took me to urgent care
and from then they said i needed to go
to the er
and
after that they sent me to the icu
even
like even when i was in the icu i was in
a hospital bed literally being told that
i could have killed myself that i could
have died
i i didn't see a problem like
they told me that
that that's when i was diagnosed with
the depression and the anorexia
and they told me that i was anorexic and
i was like
no like
that that's that it's not possible that
couldn't be me i i didn't even lose
enough like to me i didn't lose enough
weight to be anorexic which is not true
eating disorders don't discriminate
anyone any shape size color
like anyone
can have an eating disorder
you don't need to drop to a certain
weight to be anorexic um
by the time i i didn't know that i was
in so
so much denial like
i i was consumed by the eating disorder
and it was
i don't like you would think that once
you're in the icu that they're literally
telling you that
you you could have died like if you
weren't
didn't make it there
you think oh okay now i have a problem
like now i should stop
but that didn't
that didn't cross my mind at all
um
so the
anxiety the depression the
feeling like i need this validation from
other people all of that the loss of
control of my life had become a perfect
storm
for an eating disorder
the anxiety
the anxiety it soothed the anxiety for
me to have this
pattern of
i only eat this much calories i only
like exercise at these times i only
eat at these times this is all i'm
thinking about
and if i strayed like away from that
then
things like
i just couldn't handle it
um and then also the depression i was
coping with the depression
but also
it was making me more depressed at the
same time
i couldn't think about
anything that made me sad i couldn't
think about anything because i was
like
my mind was consumed with the eating
disorder um
when when you're
when you're like malnourished
and you also have this
this disorder
your brain stops working
properly
so that makes it like extremely more
dangerous because
you can't it's harder to snap snap out
of it i mean there's no snapping out of
it really but
you you have this like brain fog you're
not thinking properly and you're just
doing it more and more and more and it
to me it
was like an addiction like
i
there wasn't there wasn't ever a lower
number there wasn't ever
like a low enough amount of calories i
could eat
it
it worked so well because
it was it was a negative coping skill
it
i wasn't focused on anything else you
know um
but anyway after
being discharged from the icu
i was i went straight into residential
treatment
and even then like i got to treatment
uh with other people my age
who who were struggling with this
and i was so naive i was like what no i
don't think i belong here like you got
the wrong person like not me
um but i did have a problem
[Music]
and in treatment
it
it was a lot of emotions going on during
that time
[Music]
there was you know some good parts like
for the first time in my life i had
been around like people my age who were
understanding what i was going through
i didn't
i felt like acceptance i guess for the
first time
really
and i let's see
in treatment
i
i got discharged early the first time i
mean a lot of times
because the thing is
insurance companies don't
don't see you as a person
uh treatment is super expensive like if
you just think about it
the
if for anyone who like sees a therapist
like regularly throughout the month that
can get pricey i was literally living
in a facility with therapists there all
the time nurses the price of food
everything it gets super expensive
so
they
discharged me early despite my whole
treatment team like a professional is
telling me i needed to be there
i was still like still struggling was
not ready
to leave like at all
that time
i
i relapsed like
after treatment
and
i remember i went to like the doctor i
was doing like a checkup
um
and they're asking me like all sorts of
questions just about like how i was
doing and stuff and i was not doing well
i knew that
i needed
more help like
they're asking me if i had thoughts of
suicide and stuff and
i didn't know what what i was going to
say was going to where that was going to
get me put
i
um so yeah i was like of course
i want to die like
i i woke up like every day hating my
life struggling
not only with the eating disorder but
now
the fact that i'm getting forced
to give this up i'm being forced to eat
being forced to gain weight
i i was like i was sick
and i didn't
you know there's a time where it's like
okay you have a problem
are you gonna acknowledge that you have
a problem and then okay i have a problem
but i don't want to do anything about it
i don't
like
i didn't care if it meant being skinny i
didn't care that i literally could die
and that's extremely dangerous
um eating disorders anorexia
specifically is has the highest
mortality rate of all the mental
illnesses
and
it's not just like the effects that it
has on your body it's also because of
suicide
um
so i
when i was talking to the doctor i got
admitted to the psychiatric hospital for
the first time
and by this time like i was like 15
it was terrifying i didn't know
where i was going really
um
usually they put you on a 72 hour hold
and i was there for two weeks the first
time
and when you're in the psychiatric
hospital like at least from my
experience with an eating disorder they
did not know how to um
they didn't know how to deal with that
at all
i had doctors telling me stuff like just
eat
and don't don't focus on that right now
you're here because of your suicidal
ideation
but i wanted to kill myself because
of the eating disorder because i was
living with this thing like i could not
handle it
and
uh what else sorry
they they kept me there for so long
because usually it's a 72 hour hold for
a couple different reasons
the first one was medication
they messed with my meds so heavily
increasing the dosage adding a new one
decreasing the dosage
and that was a reason to keep me there
was to see how i reacted
to the meds
also
at this point i had been like i was
forced into treatment so i was kind of
used to eating again
but
i was only eating very very selective
foods like
i wasn't really eating
what they were serving there which is
like chicken nuggets and french fries
like i was not gonna eat that
and when you're in the psychiatric
hospital they log like everything that
you're doing they log your food
intake and stuff
so i had talked to the doctors and the
dietitian there and stuff
and they weren't really compromising
with me
um
i
i told them about like
in treatment when you don't finish a
meal they give you a drink of like
insure or boost which is like
supplements your meal
but
while i was there
they would just give me randomly give me
like even when it wasn't like meal times
they would give me the insure and the
boost
if i didn't finish a meal
they would give me
a lot like two or three and since i've
been in treatment and since my eating
disorder brain was so heavily focused on
food
i
i already knew how much ensure to expect
for like the meal like my brain could be
like oh if i didn't eat this much
protein i would get this much insurer
so
that really like
set me off that really
impacted my anxiety and the eating
disorder because they were giving me
like way too much for what i thought
was equivalent for the meals so if i
didn't finish the meal that i already
tried to eat plus these two other
insurers
they would count that as me still not
finishing the meal and since i wasn't
eating they were keeping me there even
longer
and also they were waiting for um
a bed to open up at another residential
facility because they didn't want to
discharge me from the psychiatric
hospital too early or without going
straight to another treatment
and being there for two weeks
was
was a lot i i had nightmares after
leaving there
um
i was i was really scared it
like i know i don't know what it feels
like to be in jail or anything but it
was the closest thing i felt
to that
my
the the people like i was with there was
a lot of homicidal people
and they ended up being like really
sweet but um
that was scary for me to be around
homicidal people for the first time in
my life
i again like i didn't even know where i
was going
to be put there
it was really scary
so after
after like the two weeks of being there
i got sent to another treatment facility
and
it started the cycle
of two years
i missed two whole years of high school
going into treatment being discharged
too early relapsing going back into
treatment just over and over back to
back
i also one of the times
i was discharged too early from
treatment
and
at this point
i i was done i was done with life
i you know i had struggled before with
the idea of wanting to die
but i
i
literally like
was
i wanted to die i wanted it to be over
with
i
um
so i knew i was going to get discharged
and
i had this plan like even before i left
treatment so that night
i got home like it was already set in my
mind when someone wants to kill
themselves there's no there's nothing
that's going to stop them
i went straight home
i wrote the note
i went to my garage
and my
my whole family was home
[Music]
i
and i didn't care like my dogs were
outside in the garage i loved my dogs
and
still did not that's how little like i
cared
that's how much i wanted to die
um i wrote the note i got a rope
tied it around my neck
and my dogs were all barking they're all
around me like watching me
um
and
i i hesitated for a little bit because i
i knew like you know how permanent
my decision was going to be
thankfully i hesitated because
my mom walked in she had heard the dogs
barking so much she
noticed i wasn't there
like in my room or whatever
and for some reason she decided to go to
the garage
and she found me there
rope around my neck
she found the note
and at the time like i
i wasn't thinking at all about
what she
what she must have felt
um
and i i
i did struggle a lot with feeling guilt
like about how i could do that to her
how could i put her through even just
like treatment alone she put her life on
pause for me
so i went back to the mental and the
psychiatric hospital
and this time was different
because i'd gotten so close to ending my
life that
i realized something had to change
i had already spent like year you know
years of my life the eating disorder had
taken away from me
i wasn't in school
i
knew that
i couldn't i couldn't go on like this i
couldn't spend my life
in treatment
[Music]
um
so that was like it was kind of like a
wake-up call i guess like me hitting
like that was the lowest point i had
been in my life
i was there that time for three weeks
this time
instead of
trying to like say whatever i could to
get out
trying my hardest to like pretend i
wasn't there i actually like
listened and i paid attention
um in the groups
and
i had made like this commitment to
myself that
after i left i knew i was going right
into treatment again
but i told myself like this is going to
be the last time i'm in treatment
and and it was
a lot of it
came from
[Music]
you know i
been in treatment for so long
you can't
force someone to recover
you can put them in treatment all you
want
but unless they want to do the work
unless they're they are motivated unless
they care about it
nothing's going to change
like
nothing
so this time
i i had that internal motivation
and
that's when things started to change a
little bit
that time around in treatment
i also
um started
to like separate myself from the
disorder
when i was in treatment that last time
thinking about
thinking about like my morals and my
goals
and the fact that i knew okay
i'm not gonna die
obviously like i have to try to find a
way to cope with life i have to try to
find a way
to be hopeful for my future
i realized when thinking about what i
wanted for myself in my life
that did not align with what the eating
disorder
like what
a lot of times i like to
personify eating disorders so that it
helps you with this process
so they call it ed
and my morals didn't align with ed's
morals
um so i went through treatment
i still for a couple years after i dealt
pretty heavily
with
the body image they say that
the body image the way you feel about
your body is the last thing to go i've
heard that a lot and for me it was true
you can force yourself to eat all you
want
but you're still left with this feeling
of
just like hating your body like that you
just have to like deal with
and it's so hard when you know that
you're capable of losing weight you know
what to do
to get back to that
i also when i was in treatment
i started self-harming a little bit
because
my biggest coping skill
my you know the eating disorder was
getting ripped away from me
i turned to something else
because now i'm
i don't have the eating disorder to deal
with the feelings i was feeling with and
now i'm also feeling
the
just the fact that i am losing
those be like i'm not allowed to do
those behaviors anymore that i'm being
forced to gain weight
i had to find some other way
to um
to cope with it and the thing that like
with negative coping skills is that they
work
so well they work so fast
um until until you they don't until you
lose control of yourself
and um
so that didn't
last too long the self-harm because i
was in treatment
and i wasn't trying to get sent back to
the mental hospital the psychiatric
hospital again
but fast forward like a couple years
outside of treatment
i had been trying to
recover but also
keep
keep it a secret
i had gone back to school i was in a
continuation high school
but i was still dealing very heavily
with
just all the body image issues like i
used to
for years i used to say the worst things
about myself used to say i was
disgusting and hideous like a gross
monster
now i don't thankfully don't think of
myself like that
but
that was really hard
especially with the stress of going back
to school
i ended up
um
i started smoking weed when i was like
16.
and that
i think that became some form of like
okay
now i know i have to stay
in recovery
i know i have to
i can't do any of these other things
that my parents are like watching for
they they would like
take take my door off the hinges they
would like hide all the knives and stuff
so i was like hi all the time like
i would go to before school
during school
after school
before like any social interaction
and i i knew like my parents
thought
like they're super strict i wasn't going
to fly with them
but i
did i didn't care i needed some way of
coping
after
after graduating high school
for like
a year after is when i feel like i
really truly started living in recovery
and a lot of people say living in
recovery because of the fact that
relapse is always an option and that
scares me
because i i feel like i can't trust
myself
um
like even if i'm
like years down the road doing like
completely perfect doing great
there's always the potential
for relapse
there's always a
like
it's scary because
it was so hard to get out of that place
it was
recovery from the eating disorder was
without it without a doubt the hardest
thing i've ever had to do
i i know to a lot of people it sounds
like
just a teenager wishing she was skinny
or whatever but it's it's not that like
i wish
it was that easy to just eat
it took it took
so much from my life
like away from me
it it affected my family like greatly
you know for them to know that i tried
to kill myself and that
it
it was just a lot
so now
i
it's kind of it's shocking to me
sometimes i like it's like a wake-up
call like well i'm actually in recovery
like
now i'm doing way better than i thought
i could ever do i'm eating intuitively
i don't hate my body
um
like i would have moments
like that like recently
this past summer
i took a road trip with my friends to
sequoia national park and we're driving
up the coast going to restaurants
and i realized like i'm i'm here like
i'm going to restaurants and i'm not i'm
not freaking out for even just being in
the building
i'm
i'm trying foods because
i'm looking at the menu and
i'm i'm trying to see like oh what
sounds good to me what do i want to try
versus
what's the safest option
that that really
that hit me
um the other like a couple weeks ago i
went to the doctor
and for the first time
i heard my weight
usually i would
the other doctor's office i would go to
they knew like not to tell me my weight
and i don't really recommend
anyone weigh themselves regularly
but they told me my weight
and i usually that would send me into a
spiral and like relapse
but i didn't i didn't care
and the funny part is
gaining weight was like the scariest
thing to me
um
when i was in treatment one of my
biggest fears was gaining more weight
than before i had started the eating
disorder
and now knowing that like i weigh the
most that i have ever had in my whole
life
but i'm also the most confident
now
i'm also the happiest now
because it's not eating disorders aren't
they rarely about the food
they're more so about a deeper rooted
issue
and i had to work on my mindset
to
to feel this way it wasn't about my body
you know i weigh more now
but i love myself more now than ever
what do you think the biggest factor was
was it losing your father
to like that contributed um
i think so
i think
i think it had a lot to do with
i i felt like if this one person who was
supposed to love me the most couldn't
love me then who else is going to love
me
how am i supposed to love myself
and then just going through life like
with all the kids picking on me
my mom also like divorced a second time
the unstableness
the loss of control
also added to it and then i started
focusing all my anxiety onto my
appearance
i also
do think a lot of my insecurities came
from
i went to like a lot of predominantly
white schools
so i never felt pretty because i didn't
have
blue eyes blonde straight hair small
nose
so that also added to it and just
diet cultures everywhere
you
you'd like you can realize how much us
as humans talk about food
it's a part of everyone's life
so that
i got all these messages from like a
very early age
and it all just bottled up and added to
the eating disorder
danny what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
i would say
i don't know if it's considered like a
lesson but i
think to like be happy now i had to
unlearn
and redefine what my definition of
happiness was
i spent so many years
depressed
and just
anxious and sad all the time
because i had this like false ideal idea
of happiness
i thought
a person who was happy was like had a
perfect life and nothing bothered
nothing bothered them
but
definitely now i realized that it's just
my mindset
nothing in my life
had to change
the only thing that had to change was
how i viewed it
because i was searching so much for this
idea of happiness
that it wasn't going to be possible
until i started looking at things
differently
if that makes sense
all right danny thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i'm glad
you're doing better thanks
you